Cheryl says that when her first son was born, he was everything to her, the center of her world, and he seemed happy.
Cheryl说，当她的第一个儿子出生时，他是她的一切，是她世界的中心，而且他看起来很开心。
He was affectionate, seemed to be very attached to me. He seemed to be a normal child. I don't remember seeing a lot of aggression in him when he was littler.
他很粘人，似乎非常依恋我。他看起来像个正常的孩子。我不记得他在小的时候表现出过很多攻击性。
That changed with the aggression when he was two when his little brother was born. Of course, lots of kids act out when younger kids arrive in the family. But he was extreme. He'd pinch him. He'd squish him. He'd try to hurt his little brother. Cheryl says very quickly it got the point that she and her husband could never leave the two of them alone to play. But they just thought, you know, he's hyper. Some kids are hyper. They could handle it, no big deal. AS he got older, there was other stuff like that. At three and four, he would come out of preschool and scream and yell at her, no matter what happened at school that day.
当他两岁、弟弟出生时，情况就变了，攻击性也随之而来。当然，当家里有了更小的孩子时，很多孩子都会表现出反抗。但他太极端了。他会掐他。他会挤压他。他会试图伤害他的弟弟。Cheryl说，很快情况就变得让他们夫妻俩再也不能留这两个孩子独自玩耍了。但他们只是觉得，你知道，他太兴奋了。有些孩子就是太兴奋。他们可以应付，没什么大不了的。随着他长大，还有其他类似的事情。在三四岁时，无论那天在学校发生了什么，他放学回来都会对她尖叫和大喊大叫。
And there was never any reason for his behavior. He just showed significant aggression towards me and towards his brother. And it was every day. When I look back, I realize that we've been walking on eggshells with this child since he was very little.
而且他的行为从来没有任何理由。他只是对我还有对他弟弟表现出严重的攻击性。而且是每天都这样。当我回首往事时，我意识到自从他很小的时候起，我们就一直在这个孩子面前如履薄冰。
How old was he when he first tried to kill his brother?
他第一次试图杀死他弟弟时多大？
That happened this summer, so he was seven. He decided to hold his brother under water in our backyard swimming pool. I was standing there about five feet away and felt some kind of commotion and turned around. And my son popped up out of the water, hysterical. My younger son popped up hysterical.
那是今年夏天发生的事，所以他当时七岁。他决定把他的弟弟按在后院的游泳池水下。我当时就站在离那里大约五英尺的地方，感觉到有些骚动，就转过身来。我的儿子从水里冒出来，歇斯底里。我的小儿子冒出来时也是歇斯底里的。
He'd been clawing and scratching at his older brother feet, trying to get his older brother to release him. Cheryl separated the two boys, and the older brother started yelling at her, about his feet.
他一直在抓挠哥哥的脚，试图让哥哥放开他。Cheryl把两个男孩分开，哥哥开始对她大喊大叫，因为他的脚。
And he was screaming at me and telling me that I was a bad mother for not attending to his bleeding feet, because I was taking care of my younger son and his hysterical screaming and crying, and like he was trying to catch his breath.
他在对我尖叫，说我是个坏妈妈，因为我没有去处理他流血的脚，因为我当时在照顾我歇斯底里地尖叫哭泣的小儿子，他当时好像在努力喘过气来。
The older boy had been attacking the younger one for years. But this seemed different. This was new, to take things so far that his little brother thought he might die-- no kidding. And just as disturbing was the older brother's attitude afterwards.
大儿子多年来一直在攻击小儿子。但这次似乎不同了。这很新鲜，居然把事情做得这么过分，以至于他的小弟弟以为自己可能会死——没开玩笑。同样令人不安的是大儿子事后的态度。
He did it and never acknowledged the danger of what he did. It never hits him that he could have killed his brother. It never seems to bother him that that was a possibility.
他做了这件事，却从不承认这种行为的危险性。他从来没意识到他差点就杀了自己的弟弟。那是一个可能发生的事实，这似乎从不困扰他。
Later did he show remorse?
后来他表现出悔意了吗？
No, he never has. When we would talk about it with therapists, he would just sit silent and not really participate in the conversation. He didn't defend himself, and they didn't deny it. He just sits silent.
没有，他从来没有。当我们和治疗师谈论这件事时，他只会沉默不语，并不真正参与谈话。他没有为自己辩护，他们也没有否认。他只是坐在那里沉默。
Since then, there have been other incidents. Twice he's pinned his little brother to the bed with a pillow over his little brother's face, suffocating him. Each time he kept going when Cheryl yelled at him to stop. She had to shove him off. He also has a two-year-old sister. He's thrown her across the room. And there are creepy moments, like Cheryl would wake up sometimes during the night, and he would just be standing by her bed, watching. One night after he had done that, she found a pole near the bed.
从那以后，又发生了其他事件。他曾两次用枕头蒙住弟弟的脸，将弟弟按在床上，导致他窒息。每次Cheryl对他大喊停止时，他都继续这样做。她不得不把他推开。他还有一个两岁的妹妹。他把她扔过房间。还有一些令人毛骨悚然的时刻，比如Cheryl有时会在夜里醒来，而他就站在她的床边盯着看。有一天晚上他这样做之后，她在床边发现了一根杆子。
So he had been in my room for a while, while we were sleeping. And I found this pole on the floor and realized that he had been at some point holding it in his hand while standing next to my bed while I was sound asleep and my husband was sound asleep. And it's an incredibly unnerving feeling to know how vulnerable I was at that moment and what could have happened, what choices he could have made at that moment. And I don't know what was going through his mind. He told me the next morning that he wanted to wake me up. And I said, well, why would you have the pole? Well, I was going to use the pole to wake you up.
所以他在我们睡觉时已经在我的房间里待了一会儿了。我在地板上发现了这根杆子，意识到他在某个时候手里拿着它，站在我的床边，而我正在熟睡，我丈夫也在熟睡。知道我在那一刻是多么脆弱，以及可能发生了什么，他当时可能做出了什么选择，这是一种极其令人不安的感觉。我不知道他脑子里在想什么。第二天早上他告诉我，他想叫醒我。我说，那你为什么要拿根杆子？嗯，我要用那根杆子叫醒你。
After that, she and her husband installed alarms around the house, one on his bedroom door, one on his sister's bedroom door, one on their bedroom door, one that goes off if he tries to go downstairs, plus security cameras 24 hours.
在那之后，她和丈夫在房子周围安装了警报器，一个在他卧室门上，一个在妹妹卧室门上，一个在他们卧室门上，一个在他试图下楼时会响的警报器，再加上24小时监控摄像头。
And my younger son sleeps on my bedroom floor.
我的小儿子睡在我的卧室地板上。
And when you say an alarm goes off, I don't know whether to picture a car alarm, like a big, loud like woo, woo, woo sound, or just like a buzzer goes off next to your bed so you know something's happened.
当你提到警报声响起时，我不知道该把它想象成汽车警报声，那种巨大、刺耳的“呜，呜，呜”的声音，还是仅仅像床边响起的蜂鸣器，让你知道发生了什么事。
It's the woo-woo sound. Yeah, it's loud enough that you can hear it from down the hallway. His bedroom's on the opposite side of the house. So when it goes off in the middle of the night, we hear it. It's a sound that I hear in the shower. It's a sound that I hear in my dreams sometimes. But yes, we all know when that sound goes off that it's time to be prepared.
那是“呜呜”的声音。是的，声音大到你在走廊那头都能听到。他的卧室在房子的另一侧。所以当它在半夜响起时，我们都能听到。我在洗澡时能听到这种声音。有时我在梦里也能听到这种声音。但是的，我们都知道当那个声音响起时，是该准备好了的时候了。
Have you thought to yourself, oh no. Am I raising a psychopath?
你有没有想过，哦不。我是不是在养一个变态？
Absolutely.
绝对是。
Cheryl and her husband have taken him to specialists, psychiatrists, psychologists, a neurologist, a neuropsychiatrist. At five, her son was diagnosed ADHD. He's been diagnosed with conduct disorder, oppositional defiance disorder, mood dysregulation disorder. He's on the autism spectrum. He's been on meds since kindergarten. They've tried removing privileges, removing toys, punishing him with an earlier bedtime, taking objects out of his room. They're going to keep an even tone of voice with him when he acts up. They've tried a system of rewards, where we get stars and presents for doing what he's supposed to. He's now eight years old. Cheryl's been keeping a blog about all this. Cheryl is not her real name, by the way. And she doesn't give her kids' names out either. And reading about her family's daily life on the blog, it really struck me how her older son takes real pleasure in the chaos that he creates, like in the morning, when they'll all getting ready to go to school, making loud noises, throwing food.
Cheryl和丈夫带他去看过专家、精神病医生、心理学家、神经科医生、神经精神病医生。五岁时，她的儿子被诊断为多动症。他还被诊断出患有品行障碍、对立违抗性障碍、情绪失调障碍。他属于自闭症谱系。他从幼儿园起就开始服药。他们尝试过取消特权、没收玩具、惩罚他提前上床睡觉、把房间里的东西拿走。当他闹脾气时，他们尽量保持平稳的语调。他们尝试过奖励制度，如果他表现好就能得到星星和礼物。他现在八岁了。Cheryl一直在写关于这一切的博客。顺便说一下，Cheryl不是她的真名。她也没有透露她孩子们的名字。读着博客上关于她家庭日常生活的记录，我真的很震惊，她的大儿子从他制造的混乱中获得了真正的快乐，比如早上大家准备去学校时，他大声喧哗，乱扔食物。
Don't roll your eyes!
不要翻白眼！
What you're hearing is from the security cam in the kitchen.
你听到的是厨房监控摄像头传来的声音。
Just on Tuesday, there was multiple threats to kill his brother. And he was throwing glasses of water across the room. And his little sister was yelling, mean, mean and stop it.
就在周二，他多次威胁要杀了他的弟弟。他还把水杯扔过房间。他的小妹妹在尖叫：“坏蛋，坏蛋，停下。”
You're mean. You're mean.
你很坏。你很坏。
And he'll go from one sibling to the other. And I'm protecting one sibling, and he goes after the other. And the more tense and stressful it gets, the more giddy and happy, and he finds humor in all of it.
他会从一个兄弟姐妹折磨到另一个。我保护其中一个，他就去攻击另一个。情况越紧张，压力越大，他就越得意、越开心，他觉得这一切都很滑稽。
How much of it is he likes the attention, and how much of it is-- and it's weird to use this word for a little kid-- but just pure sadism? Like he likes tormenting you all?
其中有多少是因为他喜欢这种关注，又有多少——对一个小孩子用这个词很奇怪——只是纯粹的虐待狂倾向？就像他喜欢折磨你们所有人一样？
It's a really hard one to judge. I do believe that he enjoys going after his brother purely for the sadistic nature of making his brother feel unsafe.
这很难判断。我确实相信，他攻击弟弟纯粹是因为虐待狂的本质，即让他的弟弟感到不安全。
Do you think that he does things to you because he likes seeing you suffer?
你认为他做这些事是因为他喜欢看到你受苦吗？
Yes, I do.
是的，我是这么认为的。
Of course, nobody ever wants to say a kid is just bad. And the traits that we have in childhood don't necessarily last into adulthood. There's a study that looked at teenage boys with psychopathic traits. They found that only one fifth of highly psychopathic teenagers continued to be highly psychopathic once they grew into adulthood. Among people who study and treat kids like this, there's a relatively new classification for children who don't have remorse and don't feel empathy for others. It's CU, short for callous unemotional traits. Dan Waschbusch is a psychologist and researches these kind of kids. And he says that, at this point, we do have techniques to get these kids to follow rules better, by giving them rewards. But getting them to learn empathy, that's a whole other thing.
当然，没人愿意说一个孩子就是坏。我们在童年时期的特质并不一定会持续到成年。有一项研究观察了具有心理变态特质的十几岁男孩。他们发现，只有五分之一具有高度心理变态特质的青少年在成年后继续保持高度心理变态。在研究和治疗这类孩子的群体中，对于那些没有悔意、对他人的痛苦没有同理心的孩子，有一个相对较新的分类。那就是CU，即冷酷无情特质的缩写。Dan Waschbusch是一名心理学家，专门研究这类孩子。他说，目前我们确实有办法通过给予奖励，让这些孩子更好地遵守规则。但要让他们学会同理心，那是完全另一回事。
I think that's a very difficult thing to treat. It's hard to see how you even directly address that. I don't think there's been a lot of progress in that.
我认为这是一件很难治疗的事情。很难看出你怎么能直接解决这个问题。我不认为在这方面有很大的进展。
Which leaves Cheryl and her husband in a very tough situation. And as her son has gotten older and bigger, things have gotten worse. He's gotten harder to manage. A few weeks ago, Cheryl was trying to hug him on the bed.
这让Cheryl和她丈夫处于一个非常艰难的境地。随着儿子长大、体格变壮，事情变得更糟了。他变得更难管教。几周前，Cheryl试着在床上拥抱他。
And he took his knee and he jammed it up and broke my nose.
他用膝盖用力一顶，撞断了我的鼻子。
Do you think it was accidental or intentional?
你认为这是意外还是故意的？
It was intentional. I don't know if he planned on breaking my nose, but I know he planned on hurting me. He laughed.
是故意的。我不知道他是否计划撞断我的鼻子，但我知道他计划伤害我。他笑了。
So since your oldest son broke your nose while you were hugging him, what's it been like to hug him?
那么，自从大儿子在拥抱你时撞断你的鼻子后，拥抱他是什么感觉？
It's very difficult. He has since tried to come into my bed, and he'll say I want to snuggle. I want to snuggle. And it's something that I have to choose to do, because it's not a natural reaction any longer. I have to actually make the conscious decision to hug and love the child. I've read articles about children like him that their best chance at life is to continue to get that unconditional love, and so my husband and I make a concerted effort to grab him and hug him and love him, despite everything that we've been through. But I can tell you, as a parent, I had never expected to have to force myself to hug my child in the morning.
非常困难。从那以后他试过到我的床上，说“我想依偎，我想依偎”。这是我必须选择去做的事情，因为这不再是一种自然的反应了。我必须真正做出有意识的决定去拥抱和爱这个孩子。我读过关于像他这样孩子的文章，说他们生命中最好的机会是继续得到那种无条件的爱，所以我丈夫和我都在竭尽全力去抓住他、拥抱他、爱他，尽管我们经历了一切。但我可以告诉你，作为一个母亲，我从没想过我早上不得不强迫自己拥抱我的孩子。
Of course, lots of parents experience less extreme versions of what she's going through. Most parents have moments when they think, oh my kid is a monster. But usually that goes hand in hand with, it's a phase. It's a bad day. People have faith that their kids are going to change. Well, today on our program, we have stories of children who make it very difficult for their parents to believe that, and parents who really wonder, can my kid change? And we ask, are there kids you can't do anything for? Today on our program, "Bad Babies," and the bad children they grow into-- sometimes, anyway. Very important. It is not all doom and gloom on our program today. We have stories of children who do not stay so bad as they get older, who end up, in fact, super close to their parents. Today's program I promise you will end with a hug. That's not a spoiler. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us. ACT 1:
当然，很多父母都经历过她所经历的事情的较轻版本。大多数父母都有过认为“哦，我的孩子是个怪物”的时刻。但通常这会伴随着“这是一个阶段，今天运气不好”。人们相信他们的孩子会改变。那么，今天在我们的节目中，我们有关于那些让父母很难相信这一点的孩子的故事，以及那些真正怀疑“我的孩子能改变吗”的父母。我们问道，是否有孩子是你无能为力的？今天在我们的节目中，“坏孩子”，以及他们长成后会变成什么样的“坏人”——无论如何，有时是这样。非常重要。我们今天的节目并非全是厄运和阴霾。我们有关于那些长大后并没有那么坏，反而与父母非常亲近的孩子的故事。我向你们保证，今天的节目将以一个拥抱结束。这不是剧透。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。第一幕：
Act One, Baby Not On Board. So talking with the mom who you just heard, Cheryl, this week, I found myself thinking about this interview that I did years ago. The writer Doris Lessing had just publish this novel called The Fifth Child. And I got a chance to talk to her. And this, by the way, is how I sounded on the radio back then, when I was 29.
第一幕，婴儿未登机。所以这周和刚才你们听到的那位妈妈Cheryl交谈时，我发现自己想起了多年前我做过的一次采访。作家Doris Lessing刚刚出版了一部名为《第五个孩子》的小说。我有机会和她谈过。顺便说一下，这就是我当年29岁时在电台里的声音。
In the legend of the changeling, an unlovable child is left by the fairies in place of a real human child. Doris Lessing has updated the changeling story in her latest book called The Fifth Child.
在调包婴儿的传说中，一个不可爱的孩子被仙女留在那里，代替了一个真正的人类孩子。Doris Lessing在她名为《第五个孩子》的最新著作中更新了这个故事。
OK, I'm going to stop the tape right there. Yes, I was not so good. Anyway, The Fifth Child is about what happens in a family when a baby is born into it who is not fully human. That's the story. He's born this goblin-ish sort of human and is a malevolent force from the beginning. He kills the family pets with his bare hands. From inside his crib, he injures his older brother by grabbing him and spraining his arm. And what I found myself remembering this week is how the mom in that book is treated. Everybody blames the mom for how the kid turned out-- to her face and sometimes more subtly. They act like it is her fault that this goblin is a goblin. And Lessing told me in the interview that this part of the story actually came from real life.
好了，我要在这儿停下录音。是的，我当时表现得不是太好。《第五个孩子》讲的是，当家里生下一个不完全是人类的婴儿时会发生什么。故事就是这样。他生下来就是那种像小妖精一样的人类，从一开始就是一股恶意的力量。他亲手杀死了家里的宠物。在婴儿床里，他抓住哥哥并拉伤了他的手臂，从而伤害了他。这周我发现自己记得的是书中的那位母亲受到了怎样的对待。每个人都把孩子变成这样的结果归咎于母亲——当面指责，有时表现得更隐晦。他们表现得好像这个小妖精是个妖精是她的错一样。Lessing在采访中告诉我，故事的这一部分其实源自现实生活。
And in fact, I've seen it in more than one family. One of my friends had a couple of children, perfectly normal children, and the third child was-- no one ever found out what was wrong. But it wasn't a normal child. And she went around the usual round of experts and psychiatrists and God knows what. And she said to me it suddenly occurred to her that all this time, it was taken absolutely for granted in some way it was her fault. It was her psychological attitude, and so on. And she said to one of them in a moment of revelation, how is it that no one has ever one said to me, how clever you are to have given birth to two marvellous, normal children. All you've ever said to me-- or suggested-- is that I'm a criminal. There is this is set, psychological set, an emotional set, that women get blamed for things like this.
事实上，我在不止一个家庭中见过这种情况。我的一位朋友生了几个孩子，都是非常正常的孩子，但第三个孩子——没人发现到底出了什么问题。但他不是一个正常的孩子。她走遍了通常的专家、精神科医生等等。她对我说，她突然想到，一直以来，所有人都想当然地认为这是她的错。是她的心理态度等等。她在一次顿悟中对其中一位专家说，怎么从来没有人对我说过，你生了两个如此优秀、正常的孩子，你真是太聪明了。你们所有人曾经对我说过——或暗示过——就是我是一个罪犯。这就是那种心理定势，一种情感定势，女性会因为这样的事情而受到指责。
I feel judged as a mom all the time.
我一直觉得作为一个妈妈受到了评判。
Again, here's Cheryl, the mother from the top of the show.
再说一次，这是Cheryl，节目开头的那位母亲。
I don't think there's a day that goes by that I don't feel that judgment. I feel judgment from family, from friends, from strangers, from school administrators, from teachers. I live in this constant state of guilt and judgment that I feel that if I did something different or did something better that perhaps I wouldn't have this problem. And then I have to remind myself that I have two other beautiful children that don't behave the same way. So I must be doing something right.
我不认为有哪一天我感觉不到那种评判。我感觉到来自家人、朋友、陌生人、学校管理人员、老师的评判。我生活在一种持续的内疚和评判中，我觉得如果我做了不同的事，或者做得更好，也许我就不会有这个问题了。然后我必须提醒自己，我还有两个漂亮的、行为并不相同的孩子。所以我一定做对了一些事情。
A couple weeks ago, you wrote on your blog, "I feel like I have failed my child. I can't shake that. I want to kick and scream and fight and find the next thing to try to make it better. But I know in my heart he is who he is." And reading your blog, in a couple of different spots, it seems like you go back and forth between those two feelings-- on the one hand, blaming yourself for not doing a better job at getting him to change, and on the other hand, feeling like you're doing everything you know how to do. And I'm wondering lately, which of those two feelings are you feeling more?
几周前，你在博客上写道：“我觉得我辜负了我的孩子。我摆脱不了那种感觉。我想踢、想尖叫、想战斗，想找出下一件能尝试让情况变好的事情。但在内心深处，我知道他就是他。”读你的博客，在几个不同的地方，似乎你在那两种感觉之间摇摆不定——一方面，责怪自己没有做更好的工作让他改变，另一方面，觉得你正在尽你所能做的一切。我最近很想知道，那两种感觉中你感觉更多的是哪一种？
Today I feel like a failure.
今天我觉得自己是个失败者。
Why? What happened today?
为什么？今天发生了什么？
Oh, well, today was a very rough day. He's mean. He's called me a jerk. He called me many names, tried to hurt his brother, the same things that happen on a daily basis. Just today was-- it gets old.
噢，今天是很糟糕的一天。他很刻薄。他叫我混蛋。他叫了我很多名字，试图伤害他的弟弟，这和每天发生的事情一样。只是今天——真是令人厌烦。
Do your little kids have the feeling that you can't protect them?
你的小孩子有那种觉得你保护不了他们的感觉吗？
I believe that they still feel like I can protect them. I believe my younger son feels like he can protect me. He didn't want to leave this morning, because he's afraid that my older son will get me.
我相信他们仍然觉得我可以保护他们。我相信我的小儿子觉得他可以保护我。他今天早上不想走，因为他担心我的大儿子会伤害我。
Her younger son is six.
她的小儿子六岁。
There are oftentimes when I tell him-- we have this code word where I tell him to take his baby sister to what we call the playhouse. And what that means is he has to take them to her bedroom, and then he blocks the door because my eldest son is out of control. And until I can get someone there to help me or get him under control, his job is to protect his little sister and kind of play with her. And then sometimes in those moments, he doesn't want to leave me, because he feels like he needs to protect me too. And he feels this need to be the protector.
有很多时候我会告诉他——我们有一个暗语，我让他带着妹妹去我们所谓的“游戏屋”。这意味着他必须把他们带到她的卧室，然后封锁房门，因为我的大儿子失控了。除非我能找人来帮我，或者让他冷静下来，否则他的任务就是保护妹妹，并陪她玩。有时在那些时刻，他不想离开我，因为他觉得他也需要保护我。他觉得有必要成为保护者。
That does not seem good.
那看起来不太好。
No. It's a terrible situation for him to be in.
不。对他来说这是一个糟糕的处境。
She says that all this takes a toll on the two younger kids. Her two-year-old daughter can tell when the eight-year-old's voice changes, and he's about to do something mean or destructive and will start yelling at him to stop. Both children were noticeably more relaxed and happy, she says, when the eight-year-old was recently in a hospital for 10 days. His meds were being adjusted. And Cheryl and her husband feared that if their oldest son gets to the point where he's bigger and they cannot control him, how can they keep him at home?
她说这一切对两个年幼的孩子造成了伤害。她两岁的女儿能感觉到八岁哥哥的声音何时发生了变化，他快要做些刻薄或破坏性的事情了，就会开始对他大喊大叫，让他停止。她说，当八岁的儿子最近住院10天时，两个孩子都明显更放松、更快乐。他的药物正在调整中。Cheryl和丈夫担心，如果他们的大儿子长大到他们无法控制的地步，他们该如何把他留在家里？
You know, it's a miserable way to live. And it's very difficult to have to choose. Do you choose your eight-year-old and keep him home because it's hard to send him away? Or do you choose to protect your other two children and send him away so that they can live a normal life? How do you make that decision as a mom? And I feel like if I don't find a way to save him that I will lose him to the demon that is within him. And hopefully I don't lose one of my other children or myself in that process.
你知道，这是一种悲惨的生活方式。而且不得不做出选择是非常困难的。你是选择你的八岁儿子，把他留在家里，因为送走他很难？还是为了保护其他两个孩子而把他送走，让他们过上正常的生活？作为母亲，你该如何做出那个决定？我觉得如果我找不到拯救他的方法，我就会在他体内的恶魔手中失去他。希望我在这个过程中不会失去我的其他孩子或我自己。
If you want to read her blog, it is very well written. It's at myfamilymyvillage.com. There's also a link from our website, thisamericanlife.org. ACT 2:
如果你想读她的博客，文笔非常好。网址是myfamilymyvillage.com。我们的网站thisamericanlife.org上也有链接。第二幕：
Act Two, The Road to Badness. So when does somebody turn bad? When does it happen? Can you truly be said to be bad when you're, you know, 10 or six or-- OK, here the answer's going to get more obvious-- when you're two or six months old?
第二幕，变坏之路。所以一个人什么时候变坏？这什么时候发生的？当你十岁或六岁的时候，或者——好吧，这里答案会变得更明显——当你两岁或六个月大的时候，你真能被称为坏吗？
Well, I don't think a baby can be bad in a sense of being malevolent, getting delight from the pain and suffering of others. We just don't see that.
好吧，我不认为婴儿会有一种恶意的坏，从他人的痛苦和折磨中获得快感。我们根本看不到这一点。
Paul Bloom is a professor at Yale who does experiments with babies to try to understand their sense of right and wrong, good and bad. He wrote a book about it.
Paul Bloom是耶鲁大学的一位教授，他通过婴儿做实验，试图了解他们的是非对错观念。他写了一本关于这个的书。
It's not that there's a desire to cause pain and suffering. It's not like what he said about the Joker in The Dark Knight, that some people just want the world to burn. You don't see that in babies. But what you see is selfish desires.
并不是说有一种想要造成痛苦和折磨的欲望。这不像他谈论《黑暗骑士》中的小丑那样，有些人就是想看着世界燃烧。你在婴儿身上看不到这一点。但你看到的是自私的欲望。
They want food. They want attention. They want comfort. And they do not care what anybody else wants. Also, research shows they're nicer to people they know. They don't give a damn about strangers. And they're racist. Babies are racist. OK, not exactly racist. But they prefer whatever race of people they are used to seeing and being around. If they're raised in a multiracial setting, they're fine with all the different races that they're used to.
他们想要食物。他们想要关注。他们想要舒适。他们根本不在乎别人想要什么。此外，研究表明他们对认识的人更好。他们才不在乎陌生人。而且他们有种族歧视。婴儿有种族歧视。好吧，不完全是种族歧视。但他们更喜欢他们习惯看到和相处的任何种族的人。如果他们在多种族环境中长大，他们对他们习惯的所有不同种族都没有问题。
Thinking about this as much as you do, when do you think people turn bad?
像你这样思考得这么多，你认为人们什么时候变坏？
I don't really think of that as the right question. I think that to a large extent, we start off bad. We start off with these powerful selfish impulses. And what happens mostly through acculturation and development is we become good. We become more generous. And a lot of the evil in the world is caused by people who, for whatever reason, missed out on us. They missed out on getting their morality expanded to care about other races. They missed out on the capacity to exercise their self-control. So to some extent, and this is an exaggeration, but to some extent, the most evil adult in the world is a two-year-old who never grew up, is a two-year-old who never managed to get control over his impulses. There's some studies that suggest that the peak of human violence is at age two. We are most violent of all at that age.
我不认为这是个正确的问题。我认为在很大程度上，我们一开始就是坏的。我们一开始就有这些强大的自私冲动。而主要通过文化濡化和发展，我们变好了。我们变得更慷慨。世界上许多邪恶是由那些因为某种原因错过了这些的人造成的。他们错过了获得扩展道德来关心其他种族的机会。他们错过了锻炼自我控制能力的能力。所以从某种程度上说，这是一种夸张，但从某种程度上说，世界上最邪恶的成年人就是一个从未长大、从未学会控制自己冲动的两岁孩子。有些研究表明人类暴力的顶峰是在两岁。我们在那个年龄段是最暴力的。
There's a really nice passage in your book where you write, quote, "Families survive the terrible twos because toddlers aren't strong enough to kill with their hands and aren't capable of using lethal weapons."
你的书里有一段写得很精彩，引用如下：“家庭之所以能熬过可怕的两岁，是因为蹒跚学步的孩子力气不足以徒手杀人，也没有能力使用致命武器。”
Having had two-year-olds, I truly believe that.
带过两岁小孩，我真心相信这一点。
Paul Bloom. His book about all this is called Just Babies-- The Origins of Good and Evil. ACT 3:
Paul Bloom。他关于这一切的书叫《天生的婴儿——善恶的起源》。第三幕：
Act Three, The Devil Went Down to Jersey. Now the story of a bad baby who stopped being bad as he aged. And the best possible thing happened-- all those disturbing incidents, they turned into stories that people tell. Jonathan Menjivar got them on tape.
第三幕，恶魔去了新泽西。现在是一个坏宝宝随着年龄增长不再变坏的故事。并且发生了尽可能最好的事情——所有那些令人不安的事件，都变成了人们讲述的故事。Jonathan Menjivar把它们录了下来。
The bad baby in this story, he's now a grown man in his '30s. His name is Chris Gethard. And all his life, there's been this lore in Chris's family about what a monster he was as a kid, stories so crazy they sound mythical. People even use the word evil. All this happened when Chris was around two and three, growing up in West Orange, New Jersey. And he remembers it, at least the feeling of it.
这个故事里的坏宝宝，现在是一个30多岁的成年男人。他的名字叫Chris Gethard。Chris的家族里一直流传着关于他小时候是个怪物的传说，故事疯狂到听起来像是神话。人们甚至用“邪恶”这个词。这一切都发生在Chris两三岁左右，在西奥兰治长大的时候。他记得这些，至少记得那种感觉。
I do very vividly remember having this joy that I could create chaos is how I would phrase it as an adult. Being bad was fun to me-- getting people angry and crying. And I'll go so far as to say I do also remember, in a way that is like sociopathic, I remember feeling like I ran the show. Like, I'm in charge. I'm in charge here. I get to cause things. That means I'm in charge. That's fun.
我非常生动地记得拥有一种我可以制造混乱的快乐，这是我成年后的表述。变坏对我来说很有趣——让人们生气、哭泣。我甚至会说，我记得一种类似于反社会的感觉，我记得感觉我掌控了一切。就像，我说了算。在这里我说了算。我可以制造麻烦。这意味着我说了算。那很有趣。
The person little Chris had the most fun with was his mother, Sally Gethard. Chris really made Sally suffer.
小Chris觉得最有趣的人是他的母亲，Sally Gethard。Chris确实让Sally受了不少苦。
There was a level of wisdom and aggression towards my mom that it kind of keeps me out.
对我妈妈有一种智慧和攻击性的程度，让我有点无法理解。
Take this story. One day Sally took Chris to the local A&P in West Orange to do some grocery shopping.
听听这个故事。有一天，Sally带Chris去西奥兰治当地的A&P杂货店买东西。
You have to know my neighborhood. This was not just a supermarket. This is a supermarket where her father had been the produce manager for decades. It was a supermarket my own father worked at while putting himself through college. So we went there one day. And she put me in the top part of the carriage, up in the part where the baby sticks his legs through, and you wheel him around. And we had two cats. So the first thing she bought was a whole bunch of cat food. She just loaded up the cart with cat food. That's the only thing in the cart. Now we're going down this aisle. And there's these two old Irish ladies in my very Irish neighborhood where, again, everybody knows everybody. And I had been totally fine. I'd been having a pleasant day with my mom. And I just started screaming, just crazy, over-the-top screaming, to the point where my mom was shocked. And she's going, what's the matter? What's wrong? And these old women, I have their total focus on me because I'm causing this scene, and I just bust out screaming with, "I don't want to have cat food for dinner again! Please, don't make me have to have cat food for dinner again!"
你得了解我的社区。这不仅仅是一家超市。这是一家她父亲担任了几十年农产品经理的超市。也是我父亲上大学时工作过的超市。所以有一天我们去了那里。她把我放在购物车的顶部，就是婴儿把腿伸过去的那部分，然后你推着它到处走。我们有两只猫。所以她买的第一件事就是一大堆猫粮。她只是把购物车装满了猫粮。购物车里只有那一件事。现在我们正沿着过道走。有两位爱尔兰老太太，在我那个非常爱尔兰的社区里，大家又都认识大家。我一直表现得很好。我和妈妈度过了愉快的一天。但我突然开始尖叫，那种疯狂的、过度的尖叫，以至于我妈妈感到震惊。她说，怎么了？哪里不对？而这两个老太太，她们的注意力完全在我身上，因为我在制造这种场面，我只是爆发着尖叫道：“我不想再吃猫粮当晚餐了！求求你，别让我再吃猫粮当晚餐了！”
And in, like, a whiny voice, you know?
而且是用那种呜呜的声音，你知道吗？
This is, of course, Chris's mom, Sally Gethard.
这当然是Chris的妈妈，Sally Gethard。
Like, "I don't want cat food for supper again." And you know, you can't explain to people. You start dabbling, trying to explain that, no, I don't feed him cat food, you know? And they're looking at this little, innocent child. Of course they're going to think it's true. It was almost like he was out to sabotage me. And that's what I mean. He was 2 and 1/2. How do you think of these things?
就像，“我不想再吃猫粮当晚餐了”。你知道，你没法向人们解释。你开始尝试解释，不，我不给他喂猫粮，你知道吗？她们看着这个无辜的小孩子。当然她们会认为这是真的。这几乎就像他是故意要破坏我的名声。我就是这个意思。他当时才两岁半。你是怎么想到这些主意的？
However it came to Chris's tiny, conniving brain, this wasn't an isolated incident. One day, Sally's mother was coming over, and she says this thing happened that made it seem like Chris wanted her, his mother, to get in trouble with her mother. Chris had played nice all day. He seemed excited to see his grandma.
无论这主意是怎么进入Chris小小的、阴险的大脑的，这都不是孤立的事件。有一天，Sally的妈妈要过来，她说发生了这件事，让Chris看起来像是在设局让她（他母亲）和外婆发生矛盾。Chris整天表现得很好。他看起来很高兴见到外婆。
She came in the front door. We had a staircase up to the second floor. And he was sitting up at the top of the staircase. The minute my mother walked in, he started yelling in that little whiny voice again, "me not a 'somamma' bitch." [LAUGHTER]
她从前门进来。我们有楼梯通往二楼。他坐在楼梯顶上。我妈一走进来，他又用那种呜呜的小嗓音大喊：“我不是‘somamma’的婊子。” [笑声]
What did he say?
他说什么？
"Me not a 'somamma' bitch." He couldn't even say it right, but he knew. I mean, had I ever called him that? Oh, maybe. But I hadn't just then. Then my mother would tell me, that's why he's the way he is, because you yell at him and you say things like that to him.
“我不是‘somamma’的婊子。”他甚至说不清楚，但他知道。我的意思是，我曾经这样叫过他吗？噢，也许吧。但我刚才没这么说。然后我妈就会告诉我，这就是他变成这样的原因，因为你对他吼叫，而且你对他说了那样的话。
Oh my god.
天哪。
It was like he set me up.
就像他在设计陷害我。
Chris was destructive too, to himself and everything around him. He'd shove things up his nose. He'd eat dirt. He once covered all his stuffed animals with Vaseline. He broke pair after pair of Sally's glasses. He'd snap them in half and throw them across the room with real intention and anger. He was like the Hulk in a diaper. This is Chris's dad, Ken.
Chris也很有破坏力，对他自己和周围的一切。他会把东西往鼻子里塞。他会吃土。有一次他给所有的毛绒玩具都抹上了凡士林。他弄坏了一副又一副Sally的眼镜。他会把它们折断，带着真正的意图和愤怒把它们扔过房间。他就像个穿尿布的绿巨人。这是Chris的爸爸，Ken。
Chris, when he was real little like that, he had a bit of a temper. I'm sure you heard the story about his devil mark.
Chris，当他那么小的时候，脾气有点火爆。我肯定你听过关于他“魔鬼印记”的故事。
Yeah, you heard that right. Several people told me Chris was born with this V or triangle-shaped birthmark, his devil mark. It sat right in the middle of his forehead.
是啊，你没听错。好几个人告诉我Chris出生时带着这个V形或三角形的胎记，也就是他的魔鬼印记。它就在他额头的正中央。
Apparently the birthmark was not very prominent unless I was angry, at which point it turned bright red. And my mother has actually said that it glowed.
显然这个胎记不太明显，除非我生气，在那时它会变成亮红色。我妈妈甚至说它会发光。
When Chris got angry and the devil mark was glowing, he would bite, too. Sally says Chris's older brother Greg was often the victim.
当Chris生气、魔鬼印记发光时，他也会咬人。Sally说Chris的哥哥Greg经常是受害者。
When he would bite Greg's fingers, he would just clamp down, clamp down. And I mean, I hate to even say this, but I'd smack his face to try to get him to release. I mean, Greg would be screaming. I'd be screaming. And then when he was ready, he'd let go and just walk away like he didn't do anything.
当他咬Greg的手指时，他会死死咬住，死死咬住。我是说，我甚至不想说这个，但我会打他的脸试图让他松口。我的意思是，Greg会尖叫。我会尖叫。然后当他准备好了，他就会松口，走开，就像什么都没发生过一样。
All these stories about Chris, they've become these little jokes in the family. But Chris's behavior really weighed on his mom, Sally, in a way I think any parent who's dealt with a difficult childhood would understand. It's just the piling up, day after day of dealing with a little monster, doing it full time. It breaks you.
所有这些关于Chris的故事，都变成了家庭里的笑料。但Chris的行为确实给他的妈妈Sally造成了沉重负担，我认为任何一个处理过困难童年的父母都能理解。这只是日复一日的积累，应对一个小怪物，全职做这件事。这会摧毁你。
I feel so bad because I was always yelling. And my husband would come home. I would just sit at the table and cry, because I really-- he loves when I tell these stories.
我感到很难过，因为我一直在吼叫。我丈夫会回家。我会坐在桌子边哭，因为我真的——他很喜欢我讲这些故事。
He being Chris.
他指的是Chris。
He thinks that they're hysterical. But sometimes I felt like such a failure. You know, why does my own kid hate me? And just torment-- it broke my heart.
他认为这些都很滑稽。但有时我觉得自己是个失败者。你知道，为什么我自己的孩子恨我？这种折磨——这让我心碎。
Sally had had it. She was crying every single day, not sure when or if Chris would ever stop being such a pain in the ass. And then finally, one day Chris's dad Ken decided that he'd had it too.
Sally受够了。她每天都在哭，不知道Chris何时会停止做一个讨厌鬼，也不知道他是否会停止。最后，有一天Chris的爸爸Ken决定他也受够了。
He came home, and my mom was crying. And I was walking around being all cocky about it.
他回家了，我妈在哭。我正到处走，对此感到洋洋得意。
And it was just like, enough's enough. And he called Chris over, and he said to him--
就像，受够了。他叫Chris过来，对他说——
All right, you. I've been telling you I'm going to take you down to the bad boys' home unless you straighten out. Now I'm taking you down. I made him get in the car with me.
好了，你。我一直跟你说，除非你改正，否则我要把你带到坏孩子之家去。现在我带你去。我让他跟我上车。
The bad boys' home. It wasn't a real place, of course. But just about a mile away from Sally and Ken's house, right on Main Street in West Orange, were these old factories where Thomas Edison used to have a complex. It's a national historic park now where you can see Edison's old lab. There are phonographs and movie cameras and all sorts of stuff he made there. But right next to the Edison complex is a bunch of blooming, degrading, totally abandoned warehouse buildings that Edison left behind. Those buildings, they were where Ken was taking Chris.
坏孩子之家。当然，那不是个真实的地方。但在离Sally和Ken家大约一英里的地方，就在西奥兰治的主街上，是Thomas Edison过去拥有建筑群的老工厂。现在是一个国家历史公园，你可以看到Edison的老实验室。那里有留声机、电影摄影机和他制作的各种各样的东西。但就在Edison建筑群隔壁，是一堆Edison留下来的、正在没落和荒废的仓库建筑。那些建筑，就是Ken带Chris去的地方。
And I drove up to the back of them. All right, you want to be a bad boy. This is where you have to live now. And I opened the door.
我开车开到它们后面。好了，你想当坏孩子。你现在必须住在这里。我打开车门。
He was like get out! Get out! Get out of the car! And I was like, I don't want to! And he was yelling at me to get out. And apparently at one point I went, I want to go home! And he yelled, this is your own home now! This is the bad boys' home. This is where the bad boys live. You're a bad boy. This is your home now. You live here now! And I always remember the story being that he put me out of the car and started to drive away.
他就像“出去！出去！下车！”我当时就像，“我不要！”他在冲我大喊让我下车。显然有一次我说，“我想回家！”他大喊，“这就是你自己的家了！这是坏孩子之家。这就是坏孩子住的地方。你是个坏孩子。这是你的家了。你现在住在这里！”我记得这个故事一直是这样的：他把我赶下车，然后开始开车离开。
That's not true.
那不是真的。
That part's not true, OK.
那部分不是真的，好吗。
No, that part's not true.
不，那部分不是真的。
I mean, he very clearly made me think he was going to leave me inside this abandoned warehouse.
我的意思是，他非常清楚地让我以为他要把我留在这个废弃的仓库里。
I'm not real proud that I did this. But when you're dealing with a three-year-old, logic doesn't always apply.
我不为我做这件事感到自豪。但当你面对一个三岁的孩子时，逻辑并不总是适用。
Whoa, dude. Whoa.
哇，老兄。哇。
I wanted to see the bad boys' home, so I asked Chris to take me out to West Orange, back behind the old warehouses. They're five stories tall, lots of broken windows.
我想看看那个坏孩子之家，所以我让Chris带我去了西奥兰治，回到旧仓库后面。它们有五层楼高，有许多破碎的窗户。
This is worse than I remember. There's bullet holes. Those are bullet holes. There's multiple bullet holes. You told me I had to live here. This is insane. I'm really glad we came here. I'm glad this is still standing.
这比我记忆中更糟糕。有弹孔。那是弹孔。有多个弹孔。你告诉我我必须住在这里。这太疯狂了。我很高兴我们来了这里。我很高兴它还屹立不倒。
Why? What is it about seeing it again?
为什么？再看到它是什么感觉？
I don't think I've been on this block since that night. I don't think I've actually been behind this building. And it's just so funny, because I know my dad, and he's so nice. It's just so amazing to me that three decades ago, there was a night filled with such rage that we were back here, and he was screaming at me. I must have been such a nightmare for that to have to happen. That is terrifying. This is not cool.
我想自那天晚上以来我还没来过这个街区。我想我其实没来过这栋楼后面。这太搞笑了，因为我了解我父亲，他那么好。让我惊讶的是，三十年前，那一晚充满了那样的愤怒，以至于我们来到这儿，他在对我尖叫。为了让这种情况发生，我一定是个噩梦。这太可怕了。这可不酷。
Parents, take note-- the bad boys' home, this entire scheme, it did not work on baby Chris. It scared him. But after a couple days, he went right back to his devilish ways. And then, when Sally sent Chris to preschool, the old Chris just disappeared. He turned into a nice little boy. He made friends, didn't bite anyone. He was sweet with Sally.
父母们，请注意——坏孩子之家，整个这个计划，在宝宝Chris身上根本没用。它吓到了他。但几天后，他又回到了他那魔鬼般的作风。然后，当Sally把Chris送到幼儿园时，旧的Chris就消失了。他变成了一个可爱的小男孩。他交了朋友，没咬任何人。他对Sally很甜。
The idea that she maintained any affection for me is a miracle. And I'm actually now-- I'm like a mama's boy. I once broke up with a girl because she accused me of having an oedipal complex. That's how much--
她对他保持着任何情感的想法简直是个奇迹。我现在实际上——我像个妈宝。我曾经因为一个女孩指责我有俄狄浦斯情结而和她分手。这就是我有多——
Really?
真的？
--I love my mom. She was wrong. I want to be very clear. I do not have an oedipal complex. But my mother and I are really kind of insanely close right now and have been for most of my life. It was just this one to two year stretch where I really challenged her to have love for me, based on how I behaved.
——爱我的妈妈。她是错的。我想说得很清楚。我没有俄狄浦斯情结。但我和我母亲现在真的极其亲密，而且我生命中的大部分时间都是这样。只是那一两年的时间里，我真的挑战了她对我的爱，基于我的行为方式。
Chris is a comic now, and he's still doing outlandish things. But the only person they're hurting is Chris himself. Recently he burned his body slightly from frostbite after sitting on stage for 45 minutes, completely nude in a tub of ice cream and chocolate sauce. He was supposed to be a human sundae. You could even take a bite if you wanted. It was gross and weird and maybe a little scary and funny, everything Chris Gethard has wanted to be since he was a little boy.
Chris现在是个喜剧演员，他依然在做些古怪的事情。但他唯一伤害的人就是Chris自己。最近，他在舞台上坐了45分钟，完全赤裸着坐在一桶冰淇淋和巧克力酱里，导致身体轻微冻伤。他本来应该是个人形圣代。如果你想的话，甚至可以咬一口。这又恶心、又奇怪，也许还有点吓人且好笑，这一切都是Chris Gethard从小就想成为的样子。
Jonathan Menjivar is one of the producers of our program. Chris Gethard's first comedy album, called "My Comedy Album," comes out next month. Coming up, a kid runs the cost-benefit analysis of getting spanked and comes out for spanking. More "Bad Babies" in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues. ACT 4:
Jonathan Menjivar是我们节目的制片人之一。Chris Gethard的第一张喜剧专辑名为《我的喜剧专辑》，下个月发行。接下来，一个孩子运行了被打屁股的成本效益分析，并选择了被打屁股。一分钟后，更多关于“坏孩子”的内容，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，节目继续。第四幕：
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Bad Babies," stories of people trying to figure out what to do so their kids are not so bad. And the question with some kids, is there nothing you can do? We've arrived at act four of our show. Act Four, This is Gonna Hurt Me a Lot More Than It's Going to Hurt You. About a year ago, there was this story in the news about a man in his early 30s who was going to be adopted by his long-lost foster mom, now that he was an adult. They hadn't seen each other in a long time. On the CNN story about this, they met up at the airport. It was all hugs and kisses. The man is Maurice Griffin. The mom in the story is Lisa Godbold, though she was Lisa Harris way back when Maurice lived with her. The TV report said that they had been pried apart. That is, Maurice had been removed from Lisa's home by the foster care system. One of our producers, Sean Cole, caught this story on CNN when it aired. And there was something about it that stuck with him.
《美国生活》，我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“坏孩子”，关于人们试图找出办法让他们的孩子不那么坏的故事。而对于某些孩子的问题是，是否有你无能为力的事情？我们已经到了节目的第四幕。第四幕，“这对我来说比对你更疼”。大约一年前，新闻里有一个故事，关于一个30出头的男人，他现在是一个成年人，将被他失散已久的寄养妈妈收养。他们已经很久没见了。在CNN关于此事的报道中，他们在机场重逢。到处都是拥抱和亲吻。那个男人是Maurice Griffin。故事中的妈妈是Lisa Godbold，尽管Maurice和她住在一起时她叫Lisa Harris。电视报道说他们是被强行拆散的。也就是说，Maurice被寄养系统从Lisa的家中带走了。我们的制片人之一Sean Cole在CNN播出时看到了这个故事。有些东西让他记忆深刻。
Something that confused me, actually. It was the reason Lisa and Maurice have been pride apart, which when I first heard about it, seemed to upend the very physics of both parenting and being a kid. The short version is that Maurice, when he was eight or nine years old, asked Lisa and her husband, his foster parents, to spank him when he was bad. In the TV story, Lisa says he very much wanted that which, A, I found hard to believe, and B, what mother and child, foster or otherwise, have a rational discussion about the rules of engagement for when he misbehaves? And that was just number one on a list of a million questions I suddenly had.
实际上，有些东西让我困惑。这就是Lisa和Maurice被拆散的原因，当我第一次听到它时，这似乎颠覆了为人父母和做一个孩子的物理学。简而言之，Maurice在八九岁时，要求Lisa和她的丈夫（他的寄养父母）在他表现不好时打他屁股。在电视故事中，Lisa说他非常想要那样，A，我发现这很难相信，B，什么样的母亲和孩子，无论是否是寄养关系，会对当他表现不好时的交战规则进行理性讨论？这仅仅是我突然有的一百万个问题清单中的第一个。
Mom, what time do you want to be done with this?
妈妈，你什么时候想结束这个？
So I went out to visit them in San Jose, where Lisa lives, and they told me the story starts around 1983 or '84. Lisa says she never even considered being a foster mom or adopting until she heard about Maurice. He was only three or four at that point, staying in a group home.
所以我去圣何塞拜访了他们，Lisa住在那儿，他们告诉我故事开始于1983年或84年左右。Lisa说她在听说Maurice之前，从未考虑过做寄养妈妈或领养。他当时只有三四岁，住在集体宿舍里。
I just remember that he was a really adorable little boy-- kind of shy and a little bit skittish. And I fell in love. I'll be honest.
我只记得他是一个非常可爱的小男孩——有点害羞，有点胆怯。我坠入爱河了。我说实话。
I mean, my parents were taken out of the situation altogether. There was no chance of me going back to them, because of the abuse.
我的意思是，我的父母完全被排除在情况之外了。由于虐待，我根本没有回到他们身边的机会。
They had abused you?
他们虐待你了吗？
I don't remember, but I'm pretty sure there was abuse.
我不记得了，但我敢肯定有虐待。
Almost immediately, Lisa thought her family would be a great fit for Maurice, partly because Lisa's white and her husband, Charles Harris, who's passed away now, was black. So their sons were mixed race. Maurice is mixed race. Looking at a picture of the three boys, you'd never guess which one came from a group home. The Harrises started visiting him once a month.
几乎立刻，Lisa就觉得她的家庭非常适合Maurice，部分原因是Lisa是白人，她的丈夫Charles Harris（现在已经去世了）是黑人。所以他们的儿子是混血儿。Maurice是混血儿。看着那三个男孩的照片，你永远猜不出哪一个是来自集体宿舍的。Harris夫妇开始每月拜访他一次。
Really, after about the third visit, we were just like, let's just get on with this. Let's just be a regular family. And maybe we were naive, but we just did not feel that he was this very troubled, very damaged kid. We just really felt like he needed very specific attention, and he needed good boundaries.
真的，在大约第三次拜访后，我们就像，让我们继续吧。让我们做一个普通的家庭。也许我们很天真，但我们真的不觉得他是一个非常困扰、非常受损的孩子。我们真的觉得他只需要非常具体的关注，而且他需要良好的界限。
But for some bureaucratic reason, it took five years to get Maurice released into the Harrises' care. During that time, they went through the orientation and licensing process to become foster parents and started taking in other foster kids to get some experience. In orientation, they learned that California law prohibits using corporal punishment on foster children-- no spanking. And spanking, Lisa says, was a value in the Harris household. They were Christians and firmly believed "he that spares the rod hates his son, but he that loves him, chastens him betimes." That's from Proverbs 13. Betimes just means early. Moreover, Lisa says her husband, Charles, truly felt that if his sons weren't disciplined this way, they could actually be in jeopardy later on.
但由于某种官僚原因，花了五年时间才让Maurice进入Harris夫妇的照顾下。在此期间，他们完成了成为寄养父母的指导和许可过程，并开始接收其他寄养儿童以获得经验。在指导中，他们了解到加州法律禁止对寄养儿童进行体罚——不许打屁股。而且Lisa说，打屁股在Harris家里是一种价值观。他们是基督徒，坚定地相信“不忍用杖打儿子的，是恨恶他；疼爱儿子的，随时管教他”。这是来自箴言第13章。“随时”的意思就是趁早。此外，Lisa说她的丈夫Charles真心觉得，如果他的儿子们不以这种方式管教，他们以后可能会处于危险之中。
You know, my husband came from a place where, living in the segregated South, disobeying your parents or disobeying a teacher or disobeying the white man could cost you your life. My husband saw lynchings. It was his core belief that sometimes, especially a boy, needs to be spanked, because the world doesn't give timeouts.
你知道，我丈夫来自这样一个地方，生活在种族隔离的南方，违抗父母或违抗老师或违抗白人可能会让你付出生命的代价。我丈夫见过私刑。他核心的信念是，有时，特别是男孩子，需要被打屁股，因为世界不会给你暂停的机会。
I'm sure you have your opinions on spanking. I have my opinions on spanking. To state the obvious, it's a hugely controversial issue, even though a Harris Poll last year showed 80% of American households think spanking is appropriate sometimes. That said, there are entire anti-spanking organizations who will point to countless studies about the negative effects of spanking on kids. There's also an army of pro-spankers readily available to debate those folks. What's not up for debate, though, is that in California, spanking your own children-- be they biological or adopted-- was and is legal, as long as it's not excessive and you don't leave a mark. And the Harrises spanked their kids, but only under certain circumstances.
我相信你对打屁股有自己的看法。我对打屁股也有自己的看法。显而易见，这是一个极具争议的问题，尽管去年的一次Harris民意调查显示80%的美国家庭认为有时打屁股是合适的。话虽如此，有整个反打屁股组织会指出无数关于打屁股对孩子负面影响的研究。也有随时准备与那些人辩论的亲打屁股大军。然而，毫无争议的是，在加州，打你自己的孩子——无论是亲生的还是领养的——在过去和现在都是合法的，只要不过度且不留下痕迹。Harris夫妇确实打了他们的孩子，但仅在特定情况下。
It was always related to one of two things-- outright defiance. You were told specifically to do something and you specifically did not do it. You might get a spanking. And then the second thing was safety. And Lord knows that young boys do lots of things that are dangerous.
这总是与两件事之一有关——彻底的反抗。你被明确告知要做某事，而你明确没有去做。你可能会被打屁股。第二件事是安全。上帝知道小男孩们做了许多危险的事情。
Just so I'm clear, when we're talking about spanking, are we talking about like Dennis the Menace, like I'll put you over my knee and whack you on the bottom?
为了清楚起见，当我们谈论打屁股时，我们是在谈论像《丹尼斯坏小子》那样，把你放在膝盖上拍打底部吗？
We had a little-- you know those little balls that have the--
我们有一个小——你知道那些有——的小球。
It was a ping pong paddle.
那是乒乓球拍。
No, it wasn't a ping pong paddle. It's a--
不，那不是乒乓球拍。它是一个——
It's a toy that turns out to be surprisingly hard to describe. But you've it. It's a paddle with a rubber ball attached to it by an elastic band. They took off the ball.
这是一种玩具，结果证明很难描述。但你有它。这是一个拍子，通过松紧带连接着一个橡胶球。他们拿掉了那个球。
Three swats on the butt, and that was it.
屁股上打三下，就是这样。
With some talking before and after to make sure you understood why it was happening. But since they weren't allowed to spank Maurice, the Harrises came up with a bunch of alternative punishments for him.
之前和之后会有一些谈话，以确保你明白为什么要这么做。但因为他们不允许打Maurice，Harris夫妇为他想出了一堆替代惩罚。
I had to pull weeds in their backyard. So that took hours. I'll never have a garden. Mom knows that. [LAUGHS] And push ups, and essays-- so they were all very time consuming. So spanking was a no brainer for me. You know, you get your spanking. You reflect for five minutes. And then you go out the door and get to playing again.
我得在后院拔草。那花了好几个小时。我永远不会有花园。妈妈知道这一点。[笑声] 还有俯卧撑，作文——所以这些都非常耗时。所以打屁股对我来说不假思索。你知道，你被打屁股。你反思五分钟。然后你就出门继续玩了。
It takes a pretty shrewd little kid to do a cost-benefit analysis on spanking. But the minimal time commitment it requires was actually the smaller issue for Maurice. Not being spanked like his foster brothers set him apart. It put the emphasis on foster instead of brother. And then it wasn't just the way they were punished. His brothers-- Gideon and Spencer were their names-- they got to do fun things that Maurice didn't.
需要一个相当精明的小孩才能对打屁股进行成本效益分析。但它所需的最低时间投入实际上对Maurice来说是较小的问题。不像他的寄养兄弟那样被打，让他与众不同。这把重点放在了“寄养”而不是“兄弟”上。而且这不仅仅是惩罚方式的不同。他的兄弟们——名字叫Gideon和Spencer——可以做Maurice不能做的有趣事情。
Like they would sit in the front seat if Mom wasn't there. Spencer got to sit in the front seat. At nine years old, this was a big deal. Dad had a drop-top Mustang. I wanted to sit in the front seat.
比如，如果妈妈不在，他们可以坐在前座。Spencer可以坐在前座。在九岁时，这是一件大事。爸爸有一辆敞篷野马。我想坐在前座。
Spencer got to sit in the front seat because he was the oldest. But Maurice was actually a little older than Spencer. Spencer also got to go with his dad to the flea market at 5:00 in the morning on weekends. Maurice would wake up and watch them leave together. It wasn't fair. Now adopting Maurice had been the plan all along. And at one point, Lisa and Charles asked him how he felt about the idea, just to make sure that's what he wanted too. At which point Maurice basically said, OK, here are my terms.
Spencer可以坐在前座，因为他是最大的。但Maurice实际上比Spencer大一点。Spencer还可以周末凌晨5点和爸爸一起去跳蚤市场。Maurice会醒来看着他们一起离开。这不公平。领养Maurice一直是计划的一部分。有一次，Lisa和Charles问他对此事的感受，只是为了确保这也是他想要的。Maurice当时基本上说，好吧，这是我的条件。
And I said to them, and I think I kind of threw them off, was that I wanted to be treated like your real sons. And they thought that they been. They'd show me their love and whatnot. And I said, well, there were certain things.
我对他们说——我想我有点让他们措手不及——是我希望被当作你们真正的儿子对待。他们以为他们一直是。他们向我展示了他们的爱之类的。我说，好吧，有些事情。
You know, I want to ride shotgun every once in a while. And I wanted to be able to go with Dad by myself once in a while. And I don't want to have to do push ups. If they get a spanking, I'd rather just get a spanking, not have to do push ups or pull weeds, because I don't think that's fair. It was really all about fairness. That was really what the conversation was about. That's all I remember about the conversation.
你知道，我想偶尔坐副驾驶。我想偶尔能单独和爸爸一起去。而且我不想做俯卧撑。如果他们被打屁股，我宁愿只是被打屁股，而不是做俯卧撑或拔草，因为我觉得这不公平。这完全是为了公平。那才是对话的真正内容。那就是我关于对话所记得的一切。
Is that what you remember?
这就是你记得的吗？
Absolutely. They both told me is our real sons do get spanked. And basically I'm saying, yes, please.
绝对是。他们两个都告诉我是我们真正的儿子确实被打屁股。基本上我在说，是的，请吧。
It actually caused Lisa and Charles a lot of stress. They thought they should spank him sometimes. Suddenly he thought they should spank him sometimes. And yet they knew the rules. They finally decided to consider it as a possibility. Spanking was a pretty rare occasion in the Harris household anyway. But then there was this one time, Christmas.
这确实给Lisa和Charles造成了很大压力。他们觉得有时应该打他屁股。突然他觉得他们有时应该打他屁股。然而他们知道规则。他们最终决定将其视为一种可能性。无论如何，打屁股在Harris家里是很少见的场合。但后来有这么一次，圣诞节。
I can tell that story.
我可以讲那个故事。
Please.
请讲。
Yes, this is at grandma's house. I'm pretty sure--
是的，这在奶奶家。我很肯定——
Maurice and Spencer tried to fix a broken yo-yo string by melting tape around the two ends. It melted and dripped onto the carpet.
Maurice和Spencer试着通过在两端融化胶带修复一根破损的溜溜球绳子。它融化了并滴到了地毯上。
It smouldered a spot in the carpet. And--
它在地毯上烧出了一个点。然后——
And? And?
然后？然后？
He got a spanking.
他被打屁股了。
I got a spanking.
我被打屁股了。
Did it hurt?
疼吗？
Ah, it was punishment. It's not supposed to feel good. But it wasn't abusive.
啊，那是惩罚。它不应该让人感觉好。但它不属于虐待。
Was it better than push ups and pulling weeds?
它比做俯卧撑和拔草好吗？
Yes.
是的。
Which, to be clear, he still had to do sometimes. All of the various punishments applied to all the kids now. And they might have gone on that way if nobody had said anything. But as shrewd as Maurice was, he was still nine years old, and he was still getting monthly visits from one of his social workers.
为了清楚起见，他有时还是得做那些。所有各种惩罚现在都适用于所有孩子。如果没人说什么，事情可能还会那样继续。但尽管Maurice很精明，他毕竟还是九岁，而且他仍然得到其中一位社会工作者的每月拜访。
So she came and asked how everything's going. And I said everything was going great. The conversation about adoption had come up. And she said, oh, so what does that entail? And I said, oh, I get to sit in the front seat. I get to go to the flea market with Dad every other weekend, and said, yeah, and they're even spanking me. It was nonchalant. So she was very interested in that. Tell me more about that.
所以她来问情况怎么样。我说一切都很好。关于领养的话题提了出来。她说，哦，那么这需要什么？我说，哦，我可以坐在前座。我可以每隔一个周末和爸爸去跳蚤市场，说，是的，甚至他们还打我屁股。它是随意的。所以她对此非常感兴趣。多告诉我一些关于那件事的情况。
According to Lisa, this particular social worker was very anti-corporal punishment to begin with. Lisa says the woman got angry and adamant.
据Lisa说，这位特定的社会工作者一开始就非常反体罚。Lisa说那个女人变得愤怒且坚定。
And we said, well, we believe that we understand what is good for Maurice. And if we're going to adopt him, that we can treat him the same way that we treat our own children. And so then she said, well, so are you saying that you use corporal punishment on your own children? And we said, yes. You know, we've always been very clear about that. And she said, well, I'm not really even sure that that's legal. And if you continue to do that, I may have to call in social services and examine your own family practices.
我们说，好吧，我们相信我们了解什么对Maurice有好处。如果我们打算领养他，我们就可以用对待自己孩子的方式对待他。然后她说，那么你是说你们对自己的孩子使用体罚？我们说，是的。你知道，我们一直对此非常清楚。她说，好吧，我甚至不太确定这是否合法。如果你继续这样做，我可能不得不叫社会服务部来检查你们的家庭做法。
Lisa says she got scared. She was only 24 or 25 at the time. It was she and her husband against this huge bureaucracy that, for all she knew, could take Gideon and Spencer, the other two boys, away from her, even though she knew spanking them was legal. They considered lying. OK, fine, we'll never spank Maurice. But that didn't seem right. Meanwhile, more and more voices on the social welfare side were getting involved.
Lisa说她吓坏了。她当时只有24或25岁。这是她和丈夫对抗这个巨大的官僚机构，就她所知，机构可能会夺走Gideon和Spencer，另外两个男孩，即使她知道打他们屁股是合法的。他们考虑过撒谎。好的，没关系，我们永远不会打Maurice的屁股。但这似乎不对。与此同时，福利机构方面越来越多的声音参与进来。
Most of the conversation was, won't you please change your mind?
大部分对话是，你们不愿改变主意吗？
Asking you to change your mind?
要求你改变主意？
Oh yeah, like just do this. You just need to do this. And we just felt like it wasn't right.
哦，是的，就像只要这样做。你们只需要这样做。我们只是觉得这不对。
And you felt like it wasn't right because you were so hard on your convictions or because--
你觉得这不对，是因为你对自己的信念非常坚定，还是因为——
It would make Maurice feel like he didn't belong. That was the most important thing. So it wasn't so much based on, you know, oh we absolutely believe that God says that you should spank your children. It wasn't that. It was the deeper issue of love means certain things to certain people. And you have to listen to the heart of your loved ones, whether it's your child or your spouse or your parents. What love is to them, that's what it is.
这会让Maurice觉得他不属于这里。那是最重要的事。所以它并不是那么基于，你知道，哦，我们绝对相信上帝说你应该打孩子的屁股。不是那样的。这是爱的更深层次的问题，爱对某些人意味着某些事情。你必须倾听你所爱之人的心声，无论是你的孩子、你的配偶还是你的父母。爱对他们意味着什么，它就是什么。
I talked with one of the social workers who was on Maurice's case at the time-- not the one that got angry, another one. She was much more pragmatic. She said she didn't understand why the Harrises didn't simply wait until the adoption went through to start spanking Maurice, not that she was recommending spanking. But Lisa said the adoption could have taken years. He might have been 17 by that time. Both of them told me the whole situation was heartbreaking. Maurice, of course, didn't know any of this was happening. All he remembers is one of the social workers showing up again for one of their check ins.
我和当时处理Maurice案件的社会工作者之一谈过——不是那个生气的，另一个。她更务实。她说她不明白为什么Harris夫妇不简单地等到领养完成后再开始打Maurice的屁股，不是说她建议打屁股。但Lisa说领养可能花了数年。到那时他可能已经17岁了。他们俩都告诉我整个情况令人心碎。Maurice当然不知道这一切正在发生。他只记得其中一位社会工作者又回来进行例行检查。
I was in the living room, but my back was to where the door was, was like right here. And so she was talking with me so that I couldn't see what was going on behind me. And at first, it was, how's everything going? I'm saying great. Everything's awesome. And then it was like some small talk. And then it was like, do you want to go to McDonald's?
我当时在客厅，但背对着门的方向，就像这儿。所以她和我说话，这样我就看不到我身后发生了什么。起初是，情况怎么样？我说很好。一切都很棒。然后是一些寒暄。然后是，你想去麦当劳吗？
Maurice got in the car, not knowing that all of his belongings were already in the trunk. The caseworker didn't break the news to him until they were on the freeway.
Maurice上了车，不知道他所有的行李已经在后备箱里了。个案工作者直到他们在高速公路上时才把消息告诉他。
Is an eight or nine-year-old kid equipped to, in any way, help determine how he or she should be disciplined?
一个八九岁的孩子是否有能力在某种程度上帮助决定他或她应该如何受到纪律处分？
You know, that's a really good question that I've thought about since knowing that we were going to do this interview. Looking back now, I would probably say no, especially knowing the gravity of what would happen to him afterward. No. The flip side is, had we not and he did stay in our home but continued to feel unequal, I don't know what those consequences would have been for him emotionally either. I don't have the answer.
你知道，这是一个非常好的问题，自从知道我们要进行这个采访以来，我一直在思考。现在回想起来，我可能会说不，尤其是在知道他后来会发生什么的情况下。不。另一面是，如果我们没这样做，而他留在我们的家里，但继续感到不平等，我不知道那对他情感上的后果会是什么。我没有答案。
From there, Maurice bounded around from group home, to foster home, to group home. He was basically wild, always acting out. The Harrises were able to visit him at first and talk to him on the phone. And after those phone calls and visits, he'd really act out, frustrated that he couldn't stay with them. Lisa says the house parents at one facility did a kind of backwards math, figured the Harrises were causing his outbursts somehow. Suddenly they weren't able to bring him home for Thanksgiving or Christmas. And little by little, they lost touch completely. Maurice's main caseworker kept trying to find a solid living situation for him. She was never really able to.
从那里开始，Maurice从集体宿舍跳到寄养家庭，再到集体宿舍。他基本上很野，总是在反抗。Harris夫妇起初还能拜访他，并在电话里和他交谈。在那些电话和拜访之后，他会非常反抗，因为无法和他们住在一起而感到沮丧。Lisa说，一个机构的寄养父母进行了一种反向计算，认为Harris夫妇以某种方式导致了他的爆发。突然间，他们不能带他回家过感恩节或圣诞节了。一点一点地，他们彻底失去了联系。Maurice的主要个案工作者一直试图为他找到一个稳定的居住环境。她从来没有真正做到。
But they wanted to. They really wanted me to be happy somewhere else. That's why they kept putting me in a lot of foster homes. But that was like I was cheating on my family. I have a family. Why are you trying to give me another one? In my young mind, I just thought that if I don't behave anywhere that I'll be back with my family.
但他们想。他们真的想让我在别处开心。这就是为什么他们一直把我放在许多寄养家庭里。但那就像我在背叛我的家人。我有家人。你们为什么要试图给我另一个？在我年轻的思想里，我只是认为如果我在任何地方都不表现好，我就能回到我的家人身边。
Oh, so if you were impossible to care for--
哦，所以如果你很难被照顾——
Right, impossible. And I was impossible. They'll run out of places to send me and send me home.
对，很难。而且我确实很难。他们会没地方送我，就会把我送回家。
By the time he was about 16, Maurice was so out of control he wound up in the military-style boot camp for troubled kids in Nevada. He wasn't spanked there, of course, but he says their restraint tactics were brutal. Police have investigated reports of abuse at this place in the past. Maurice ultimately escaped. He says the juvenile hall in Reno refused to send him back because of all of his bruises. I genuinely think that the juvenile system was trying to protect Maurice when it took him away from the Harrises. But given what happened, it's hard to think that they succeeded. Around the time he turned 18, Maurice started actively-- not to say doggedly-- searching for the Harrises again. He combed through phone books, searched all of their names online-- Lisa and Charles Harris separate, together, Gideon, Spencer. He even made a pilgrimage back to their house at one point, the house he grew up in for 18 months. They didn't live there anymore. This also happened to be around the time that Charles died of a heart attack. Lisa eventually got remarried and changed her name, moved to a different state. Maurice kept looking for her through college and after. He never stopped. And then finally, about 20 years after he first went to live with her, he opened up his Myspace account. And there was a message from Lisa.
当他大约16岁时，Maurice如此失控，以至于他最终去了内华达州为问题少年开设的军事化训练营。当然，他没被打屁股，但他说是他们的约束策略很残酷。警方过去曾调查过该地虐待报告。Maurice最终逃跑了。他说雷诺的少年拘留所因为他所有的瘀伤拒绝把他送回去。我真诚地认为，少年司法系统在把Maurice从Harris夫妇身边带走时是试图保护他。但鉴于后来发生的事情，很难认为他们成功了。大约在他18岁时，Maurice开始积极——不是说坚韧地——再次寻找Harris夫妇。他翻遍电话簿，在网上搜索他们所有的名字——Lisa和Charles Harris分开搜索、一起搜索，Gideon、Spencer。他甚至有一次去他们家朝圣，那是他长大的房子，住了18个月。他们不再住那里了。这也恰好是Charles心脏病去世的时间左右。Lisa最终再婚并改了名，搬到了另一个州。Maurice在大学期间和之后一直寻找她。他从未停止。然后最终，在他第一次和她住在一起大约20年后，他打开了他的Myspace账户。那里有一条来自Lisa的信息。
I sat there. I just remember staring at the screen, like I've been looking for so long, and there she is. And I picked up the phone and I called the number. And she picked up, and she said, hi, son. And I said, I'm going to have to call you back. I just hung up the phone.
我坐在那儿。我只记得盯着屏幕，就像我寻找了这么久，而她就在那儿。我拿起电话，拨了这个号码。她接了，她说，嗨，儿子。我说，我得给你回电话。我就挂了电话。
It's hard to carry on a coherent conversation when you're crying your eyes out.
当你哭得双眼红肿时，很难进行连贯的对话。
I really didn't know if he would even want to have any contact with me. I just assumed that he would look at me as another person that abandoned him. I mean, that's the way I would feel. But I think that every person, especially kids that are trying to survive in the system, they write a script for themselves. And they play that script over and over again, and that's how they survive. And I'm very blessed that the script that Maurice wrote for me is that I was his mom and I loved him.
我真的不知道他是否愿意和我接触。我只是假设他会把我视为抛弃他的另一个人。我的意思是，这就是我的感受。但我认为每个人，尤其是那些试图在系统中生存的孩子，他们为自己写了一个脚本。他们一遍又一遍地演那个脚本，那就是他们生存的方式。我很幸运，Maurice为我写的脚本是我就是他的妈妈，我爱他。
It's so good. It sounds like you blame yourself more than he blames you.
这太好了。听起来你责怪自己比他责怪你要多。
I do.
我是。
Can I stop for a second?
我可以停一下吗？
Ah, yeah, maybe.
啊，是的，也许吧。
When I was interviewing them at Lisa's house, the lawn mower guy started making all this noise outside. So we took a break. Maurice got up, grabbed a photograph, and brought it over.
当我在Lisa家采访他们时，割草机那个人在外面弄出很大噪音。所以我们休息了一下。Maurice起身，拿了一张照片，把它拿了过来。
Oh, wow. That's a beautiful picture.
噢，哇。那是一张漂亮的照片。
It was a family shot, present day, Lisa standing next to all of her sons-- Gideon, Spencer, and Maurice. And even now--
那是一张家庭合影，现今，Lisa站在她所有儿子身边——Gideon、Spencer和Maurice。即使现在——
Yeah, you're right. I cannot.
是的，你说得对。我不能。
You really can't tell.
你真的分辨不出来。
I really, really can't tell.
我真的、真的分辨不出来。
Really, really can't tell.
真的、真的分辨不出来。
You can't tell which one of them is adopted.
你分辨不出他们哪一个是领养的。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our show. ACT 5:
Sean Cole是我们节目的制片人之一。第五幕：
Act Five, We Are Fine Parents. We close today's program with this fictional story of a bad baby by John Jodzio, read first by actress Sarah Mollo-Christensen.
第五幕，我们是很好的父母。我们今天以John Jodzio的这篇关于坏宝宝的虚构故事结束今天的节目，首先由女演员Sarah Mollo-Christensen朗读。
Our baby swallowed a ninja star, and then it swallowed a bakelite button. It seemed fine, breathing and everything. We checked. We are fine parents. We weren't too upset about the button, but the ninja start was one of my husband's favorites, really light, and made from this tungsten polymer that was said to be space age. He used it in the league that he was in on Thursday night. "I'll never ever find another one like that again," he told me privately. The same thing happened with our nail clippers. One night I found the baby standing on top of our bathroom sink, rifling through the medicine cabinet. "The nail clippers are gone," my husband told me, after taking stock. "They were right here on this shelf, and now they're not." "Maybe you left them downstairs," I offered. "Maybe you're mistaken. Maybe you left them somewhere, and you forgot. Maybe you were there one." My husband had just gotten out of bed, and his hair was matted down. It looked like when a helicopter comes down suddenly in high grass, pushed out in spots, flattened down in others. "Whose side are you on here?" he asked me. "No one's," I told him, "and everyone's." Soon my husband and the baby were eying each other in a manner I did not like. One afternoon, my husband searched the baby's bassinet. "This is a random search," he told the baby. "It could occur at any time. That's what random means, OK?" The baby took its revenge for the search by swallowing my husband's wrist watch. "It's on," my husband told me. "That was an heirloom." More things disappeared inside the baby-- pellets of rock salt, packs of Post-It notes, a diamond solitaire necklace-- gone, finito, see ya. Sometimes I put my head right up to the baby stomach, my ears to its skin, listened carefully to its innards to see if I heard any of these things moving along. Finally, I started leaving things out for the baby to swallow-- a puzzle piece with no matching puzzle, a broken half of a letter opener, a combination lock to which we'd forgotten the combination. I put these things in plain view. "Here," I said. I gave the baby one of those sudden, "hey hey, over here" moves you give with your hands. No dice. "Maybe it's just a phase," I offered later that night after the baby was asleep. "Maybe we'll look back on this and laugh." "Does this feel like a phase to you?" my husband asked. "To me, it feels like a calculated effort to strip us of our authority while simultaneously crushing our souls." I did not want to think badly of our baby, with its sleepy hazel eyes that resembled my husband's, with its mouth that was clearly mine. That said, I'd seen too many looks of gleeful malice pass across its face not to wonder if this was a brilliant plan to drive us slowly insane. "Maybe we could swallow something the baby loves," I said. "Maybe we could get the baby to understand us better if we stoop to its level." The next morning, my husband swallowed a slice of the baby's blankie. "We'll continue down this path until we agree to a truce," he explained to the baby. "A truce is an agreement between two parties to stop fighting, all right?" The baby squawked incoherently. It swallowed the salt shaker in protest. I'd had enough. I picked up the baby's favorite stuffed animal, this elephant called Mr. Pickles. I motioned to my husband to come with me to the bathroom. The baby followed. My husband held down the toilet handle. I held Mr. Pickles over the bowl. "I'll do it," I told the baby. "Don't think I won't." My hand was shaking, but the baby could tell I was serious. Soon the baby's eyes softened. It held out its arms. "Truce?" my husband said. The baby nodded. My husband and I smiled and nodded at each other, happy to finally have leverage, and handed back Mr. Pickles to the baby. "We are fine parents," we said, as we watched Mr. Pickles quickly disappear down the baby's throat. "Let's get some fresh air," my husband said the next day. We walked to a playground a few blocks away, put the baby in the sandbox. While we stood there, a little red-haired baby reached into a woman's purse and started to swallow things left and right-- bobby pins, a take out menu, her keys. The woman noticed us looking on. "We thought we were the only ones," my husband said. "You're not special," the woman laughed. "All of them do it." My husband and I looked around at the chaos of the playground. We saw the weary faces of the parents, the babies running rampant, the adults at their mercy. Soon, our baby got bored with the sandbox and walked over to us. He reached up for a hug and, of course, we hugged him.
我们的宝宝吞了一颗忍者星，然后它吞了一颗胶木纽扣。看起来没事，呼吸什么的都有。我们检查过了。我们是很好的父母。我们对纽扣没那么难过，但忍者星是我丈夫的最爱之一，非常轻，由这种被称为太空时代的钨聚合物制成。他周四晚上参加的联赛里用了它。“我永远、永远找不到另一个那样的了，”他私下对我说。我们的指甲剪也发生了同样的事情。一天晚上，我发现宝宝站在我们的浴室水槽上，在药柜里翻来翻去。“指甲剪不见了，”我丈夫清点库存后告诉我。“它们就在这个架子上，现在没了。”“也许你把它留在楼下了，”我提议。“也许你搞错了。也许你把它留在什么地方，忘了。也许你当时是一个人。”我丈夫刚起床，头发乱糟糟的。看起来就像直升机突然降落在高草丛中，有些地方被推开，有些地方被压平了。“你现在站在哪一边？”他问我。“哪边都不站，”我告诉他，“也站在每个人那边。”不久，我丈夫和宝宝用我不喜欢的方式盯着对方看。一天下午，我丈夫搜查了宝宝的摇篮。“这是一次随机搜查，”他告诉宝宝。“它可能随时发生。随机就是这个意思，好吗？”宝宝为了报复这次搜查，吞掉了我丈夫的手表。“开始了，”我丈夫告诉我。“那是传家宝。”更多的东西消失在宝宝肚子里——岩盐颗粒、便利贴、钻石单石项链——都没了，完了，再见。有时我把头贴在宝宝的肚子上，耳朵贴着它的皮肤，仔细听它肚子里，看看是否听到这些东西在移动。最后，我开始把东西留出来给宝宝吞——一个没有配套的拼图碎片、一把折断的开信刀一半、一个我们忘了密码的密码锁。我把这些东西放在显眼的地方。“给，”我说。我给了宝宝那种你用手做的“嘿嘿，在这儿”的突然动作。没用。“也许这只是一个阶段，”那天晚上宝宝睡着后我提议。“也许我们回过头来看这个会笑出来。”“这感觉像是一个阶段吗？”我丈夫问。“对我来说，这感觉像是一个经过计算的努力，旨在剥夺我们的权威，同时摧毁我们的灵魂。”我不想对我们的宝宝有坏想法，它那长得像我丈夫的困倦榛子眼，那长得明显是我的嘴。话虽如此，我见过太多掠夺性的恶意掠过它的脸，不得不怀疑这是否是一个驱使我们慢慢发疯的绝妙计划。“也许我们可以吞下一些宝宝喜欢的东西，”我说。“也许如果我们降低到它的水平，我们能让宝宝更好地理解我们。”第二天早上，我丈夫吞了一片宝宝的小毯子。“我们会继续走这条路，直到我们达成休战协议，”他向宝宝解释。“休战是双方停止战斗的协议，好吗？”宝宝胡乱尖叫。它为了抗议吞下了盐罐。我受够了。我拿起宝宝最喜欢的毛绒玩具，这头叫Mr. Pickles的大象。我示意丈夫跟我去浴室。宝宝跟着。我丈夫按下马桶手柄。我把Mr. Pickles悬在碗上方。“我会这么做的，”我告诉宝宝。“别以为我不会。”我的手在颤抖，但宝宝看得出我是认真的。很快，宝宝的眼睛变柔和了。它伸出双臂。“休战？”我丈夫说。宝宝点点头。我和我丈夫微笑着互相点头，很高兴终于有了筹码，把Mr. Pickles交还给了宝宝。“我们是很好的父母，”我们说，看着Mr. Pickles迅速消失在宝宝的喉咙里。“让我们出去透透气，”我丈夫第二天说。我们走到几个街区外的一个操场，把宝宝放进沙坑。当我们站在那儿时，一个红头发的小宝宝伸手进了一个女人的钱包，开始吞这吞那——发夹、外卖菜单、她的钥匙。那个女人注意到我们在看。“我们以为我们是唯一的，”我丈夫说。“你并不特别，”那个女人笑了。“所有宝宝都这样。”我和我丈夫环顾着操场的混乱。我们看到了父母疲惫的面孔，横冲直撞的婴儿，任由他们摆布的成年人。不久，我们的宝宝对沙坑感到无聊，朝我们走来。它伸出手要拥抱，当然，我们抱了它。
Sarah Mollo-Christensen, reading a short story by John Jodzio. He's the author of two short story collections, including If You Lived Here You'd Already Home, where a version of this story appeared. ACT 6:
Sarah Mollo-Christensen，朗读John Jodzio的短篇故事。他是两本短篇小说集的作者，包括《如果你住在这儿你已经到家了》，这个故事的一个版本出现在其中。第六幕：
Our program was produced today by Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, and me with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjiva, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder, production help from Alison Davis. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris, and Julie Beer, music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis. [ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS] Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Torey Malatia. You know, he's a really adventurous guy. But we had dinner the other the night. He was strangely afraid of the pate.
我们今天的节目是由Sean Cole、Stephanie Foo和我制作的，还有Alex Blumberg、Ben Calhoun、Sarah Koenig、Miki Meek、Jonathan Menjiva、Brian Reed、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike。我们的高级制片人是Julie Snyder，制作协助来自Alison Davis。Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的行政助理。Adrianne Mathiowetz管理我们的网站。研究协助来自Michelle Harris和Julie Beer，音乐协助来自Damien Graef和Rob Geddis。[致谢] 我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia。你知道，他是个非常有冒险精神的人。但我们那天晚上一起吃了晚饭。他奇怪地害怕那个肉酱。
I don't want cat food for supper again.
我不想再吃猫粮当晚餐了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。